From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Monday, May 23.
John, can I go here?
Here we go.
Now this is Monday, May 23, 2011.
We're in Summit (Argo), Illinois, with Rev. Wheeler Parker Jr.
to do an oral history interview for the National Museum of African American History and Culture and Library of Congress and their joint project entitled The Civil Rights History Project.
My name is Joe Mosnier of the Southern of the World History Program at University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
And I'm with videographer and filmmaker John Bishop.
Again, Reverend Parker, thank you very much for joining us and fitting us into your schedule as we came here to Chicago.
My pleasure.
Thank you.
I wanted to start.
Maybe we'll start with an event that's very recent and work our way back through the history.
You were just down in Mississippi for the unveiling of a historical mourn for the Bryant store.
And I wonder if you could maybe start there in our conversation today and talk about that experience and your thoughts and feelings about that.
Yes.
We were at the Freedom Trail.
They're going to do like 25 markers and the Emmett Till markers at the Bryant's Grocery and Meat Market number one.
And it was a very moving, overwhelming event and well put together.
I was very pleased with the marker and the program that they had there.
So I bought back memories.
I'm right down the road from where I used to live and cross the way I went to school.
This way I bought back a lot of memories, of course, the event of the store that day.
And that marker represented marker tells us where we were, 1955, where we are today and what we need to do.
So it was a very, very moving event, well put together, well managed.
And I give a lot of kudos to the people that it.
How often have you traveled to Mississippi in recent years and decades?
I'm probably down here about twice a year, sometimes more.
I love to go to Mississippi, let's home.
Then along with the land and the dirt the people went to, who the Mississippi is, okay?
You moved to Chicago, I think in 47.
Moved to Summit (Argo) right outside Chicago, in 1947.
You just mentioned your memories in Mississippi.
Can you maybe take us through what you saw and experienced when you put a push of a landscape when you got off the train back in 55
when you were there for that summer visit?
What about the house, the landscape, the little town and money, what?
How would you describe all that?
Country.
Country, I saw you could say, I think in money it may have been 50 people, 50 people they're about.
Give a take a little bit.
And that's good, rich, delta soil.
You don't want people on this for growing crops.
And it was ideal for that.
And that's what we did.
When we got there we got busy, got our cotton sacks, and went to the cotton field.
I think I'm eating about eight bucks that week.
So it was a fun time for me, swimming, and you know, 16 years.
We did, but 16 years, teenagers did, and we had a great time until.
Can you paint a picture of your grandpa?
Um, a grandfather, can I say about, what can I say about Papa?
No nonsense.
We carried himself.
He carried himself with dignity and great respect.
And he got great respect from people.
Gentle, man, always willing to help.
But he carried himself in that kind of way that people really respect him.
They looked up to him.
He was a man of means.
Said what he meant.
What he said.
How much grandma?
Grandma was easy going.
Grandma was so easy going that her son's asked her, want to say,
mama, when are you going to whip us?
That's pretty easy going.
Now, my mother, I went and asked her.
She was a school teacher, very lovable lady, and just believed everything her boys said.
And she was just a very likable person, you know, to know her as a delivery.
How about the, you know, say a little more just descriptively about the house,
about the little town money, about the, about the, a dark field road?
Um-hmm.
Going down Darfair Road, and I can't get the directions ready, going Darfair Road from
Bryant's store to the left is like a body of water.
I can remember when I like seven years old we lived there.
And this, I forgot what we called it, it was just overflow and our houses on the other side of the road.
And water would run under the house all night, watch the bridges out.
And you couldn't, it was fun to us, you know, sell this water.
Clear water, you could see fish is going, but it wouldn't build up because it was going back
to the opening and then back.
And we wanted to play in it, didn't know the seriousness of it, like just what happened, you know.
But to the, and where the water was running, that's where the crop screw.
I mean, cotton go right up to the house, you can go out the window, go to work right there.
Everything's right there.
And remember when we lived there, we lived next door to my grandmother.
There's like a food orchard between and we lived next door in the shotgun house, brand new shotgun house.
We lived in, and the next to us was a sawmill, actually experienced lumber being made.
Bringing these big logs in, and man, this big saw, it would be screaming, you know, cutting that wood.
So it was right there with the congregation of a clump of people right there.
And other than that, you just got cotton fields.
Not much in terms of corn, edible, vegetable, cotton was the main thing.
We had a train that ran not too far away.
We had a church right nearby where I started school, one room, one teacher taught everybody.
And she had much order.
I remember once my uncle made the teacher kind of angry.
And he told us she laughed like a duck.
So she had him to go out and bring some switches in.
And I was terrified.
This lady's going, kill us, you know, back then.
She was open, just open to be had, you know.
So she had no trouble, I was only about seven years old.
And of course, the next year went up town.
Our lab becomes up town.
It's still very rural and very country.
And I went to school up there where we did have classrooms.
So it was a very wonderful experience.
And I remember the cemetery was right by the church.
I understand now because they didn't have anything to take anywhere.
So they buried you right outside the church.
Same place they had planned.
They had dug a grave for him at the till.
So that's what I remember.
And some people live back down in the woods like.
They were all surrounded by a farm there.
Everything is farming.
Few settlements, but everything related to the farming.
And up town we had three or four stores,
whatever, very few stores.
And that was the extent of it.
You didn't know anything about fast food,
so they had to cook three times a day.
I mean, you had to eat.
You could not go into the cotton field with no cornflakes.
We never heard of cornflakes in cold series.
Like, you had to eat some rabbit, some chicken,
and some cornbread to go out of that field.
Because that son was zapped at milk out of you real quick.
So we had a wonderful, it was a wonderful time.
You know, we just didn't know anything else.
I'll tell people, I say, I love picking cotton.
I love the country.
It's a year and a half.
So I didn't stay that low enough.
But they were bragging on us.
And then I can remember the fall.
Come time because you could only go to school
after the cotton was in.
So my date was like 18 years old,
when you got a graduate from my eighth grade.
Because you have to put in so many hours to finish a grade.
So you started after the cotton was in, maybe in November.
So you'll always be a hang.
And I think what it's remarkable is that they held
to the fact that you had to have so many quarters
or whatever it was in the past.
And so he's 18, you know, they agreed.
But they held to the land.
Got one in school books.
From 19, I think, 25.
And he's telling about it.
He met my mother in his heart.
We're really happy that day.
So we have a lot of history there.
And those are the things you kind of remember.
The little things like that that happened around the farm.
When you got on the train to head back down to,
you said the end in 55.
But was you moving just one of General enthusiasm
and looking forward to the trip?
And how did you also carry a few, some sense of it's
not the place I now know.
It's not Chicago. It's a different place.
I need to shift my bag or was that in your mind at the time?
For sure.
I said I was born.
And you always heard the stories.
Very much aware of where you're going.
So you're going down behind Iron Curtain.
They equated it with going to, at that time,
Russia was called Iron Curtain.
You knew exactly, at least I did,
knew exactly where you were going and what could happen
because they told you the stories of things
that had happened to people.
And you knew that you had no protection under the law
or anything happened where you were there.
And when I went into that store,
that's one thing struck me.
When I got down, it was very much aware of it.
But your friends, we had so much fun.
Man, it should have been a lot of fun.
We just had to get fun with nothing, you know.
And swimming and just,
and most tell a lot of jokes and lies,
that's what they were telling.
Sorry, it was, you very much aware of where you were going.
At least I was.
They made you, because they weren't just around.
And they knew what could happen.
They knew what had happened,
what was happening, and what could happen.
And what did happen, that's what they were afraid of.
How long you going to stay that summer?
I don't know.
I think we're going to stay a few weeks.
Definitely longer than we had.
Then we stayed.
We don't say the week.
Yeah, we were on the death three,
three days before this incident happened,
from Sunday to Wednesday, you know.
And everything has got out of kil'ton right there.
Tell me a little bit about how you remember those first couple of days
before the Wednesday evening at the store?
Picking cotton.
And I was right at home, you know.
I think I picked about seven.
When I left, at six years old, I could pick a hundred pounds of cotton.
Right now, I could have probably picked a hundred,
but it was so hot.
Cotton saw a bloom in late August.
It's not the full bloom.
And it's so hot, you cannot stay out there all day.
So you pick the half of the day.
And sometimes we go swimming.
I remember they said snakes wouldn't bite in the water.
So we beat the water and tried to run the snakes.
I only see the snakes a little here at swimming.
And we jumped in there.
I didn't have good sense jumping in with the snakes.
Swimming and I would go with somebody
with a watermelon patch.
And together, and jokes is the number one thing down south.
I mean, everybody just seemed like a new jokes with me, you know.
And my uncle, Jai, he's my age, and we ran around in a car.
And he let me drive.
Man, it was a fun time.
I was having a ball.
And the girls around, and it's just a great time.
Yeah, a great time.
I mean, let me have you describe that late Wednesday
when I guess you all come home and you have supper and then decide to...
I'll go to the grocery store.
Sure.
Well, I think it's a bad idea.
After a short pause, just to check out equipment.
From Parker, I was just about to raise this.
Now we turn to things that are much less memories,
much more complicated, much less happy than ones we're just describing.
Can you talk about that the second half of the day on Wednesday
of that visit, on August 55?
We got that at Sunday.
And Wednesday was the first day that we rode to this little town.
I guess it was about three miles down the gravel road.
And still excitement.
But Teenage just got a car to yourself, so that was great.
And...
So you ended the day correct?
Yeah, near the end of the day,
wasn't quite dust, we were by the time we left.
We'll see, I can't remember how long we saw this.
So we get the town and people gathering up from the little settlements there.
And it's still a small town.
It's not like Greenwood and the guys out there playing checkers.
And I decided to go into the store and purchase some things.
I don't know what I purchased, but I went in there and purchased some things.
And while I was in the store, Emmett came in.
And when Emmett came in, I felt this apprehension,
because I knew how he was, not knew where we were.
It's good.
So I left Emmett in the store, and Simeon Wright came in right behind him.
Then the both of them came out of the store.
And after they came out and facing the store, Carolyn Bryant Donham came out.
She's walking to facing the store to the right of the store.
And Emmett whistled.
And we just could not believe.
I mean, this is like something out of the sky blue, you know.
Where did this come from?
What's wrong with him?
And even now, we don't know what possessed him.
He had no idea where he was.
He had no idea.
He didn't have an idea of danger.
And so she proceeded to go around.
And somebody said that she's going to get a gun.
I think that's when we start rushing to the car.
I don't know how many it was in the car.
It was a lot of us in the car.
We rushed to the car.
By this time, Emmett is scared.
We get in the car and someone has dropped a cigarette on the floor.
Two young people are smoking anyway.
But anyway, someone dropped a cigarette.
So Emmett is telling my uncle, let's get going.
Let's get going. Let's get going.
They want to find this cigarette before we start promoting us.
Uncle Fann take off. He's younger than I am.
I'll be here 16.
So we found it takes off.
And then we go down this gravel road across the river track.
Down the gravel road.
We look behind, man.
Dust is flying everywhere.
And there's a car behind us.
Oh my goodness.
Where did it come from?
I mean, this is the country.
We didn't see any car.
I was saying, there's a car right there.
And so we, Uncle, spared up and pulled to the side.
And man, I don't know if we can let it, can't stop before we jumped out and run into the car and feel.
I remember Emmett running and falling.
And people falling over one another.
And the cotton bowls that were not fresh, they were still having fresh.
They're open up.
They were beating our legs and car went right by.
Nothing to that.
We regrouped at the edge of the road and sent him.
I don't know why.
I was just sitting there.
Same goes 12.
12 was different from 16.
You know.
He's still sitting there in the car.
So somewhere in between there, we started talking and Emmett asked us not to tell my grandfather.
And of course, there was a girl that she said, I know those people.
And this is not over.
You're going to hear more about this.
You grew up with you at that time, though.
No, no.
She was, we met up with some, we stopped at someone's house.
I think we all got the house.
Of course, she says she was driving the car.
I should say for the record, you're alluding to all the representations made about these circumstances.
But people who look back were not there.
That's one of them.
Correct.
Yeah.
She says she was driving.
The imagination is powerful.
But anyway, we met and we talked.
At this point, we didn't take it serious.
I felt a relief.
You know, the car went by.
And it's like, it's going to go away, you know.
I didn't feel we're going to really hear anything more from this.
I really did.
You know, I knew what he did was a no-no.
And so that night went by.
I didn't tell my grandfather.
I don't think anybody told me.
I don't think he really ever heard.
There's been questions about that.
So when is it went by?
There's nothing.
We didn't even talk about it again.
I don't ever remember us talking about it again at all.
We forgot about it till some degree.
There's been by Friday, went by Saturday, and Saturday in the country.
And everybody goes to the big town.
Man, we went through a green wood and people from everywhere.
All the girls and the guys, and they're walking down Johnson Street.
Man, it was just excitement to see all these people coming in their car.
They're wagging and doing their shopping for the week, whatever.
And we stayed there.
And then about 12 of them, about we left.
Stopped by a place called Four Fifths, I believe.
And I still there.
I was talking about it the other day.
And it's one of those they called Jook joints.
Somebody's house, they got drinking and stuff.
And we stayed there, and we got home, I guess.
We left there on our way home.
Maurice Emmett and myself.
And my uncle Maurice, he didn't got a little hat.
And he ran over dog.
And when he ran over dog, Emmett started crying.
And he had a meaty dog to the, to the big industry.
Anyway, Emmett was very fond of animals.
He had a sensitive side for animals.
So we got home and went to bed.
I slept with Maurice, an image that was semi-unit.
And my cousin Curtis is here by now.
But he hasn't been working the last few days.
No, Curtis, we get, we get it like home Curtis, that we haven't seen.
He told the story would happen to Stordo.
Yeah, yeah.
So Gordon, before you go forward with that story,
if I forgive him for not asking, take you back just for a moment.
He said, I'm going to go that we're calling to visit the Brian Stordo.
W. Stepton, and then Emmett came in behind you.
You felt a little, just instinctive apprehension.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Not all the rules and the, the info.
I know him.
I live next door to him.
Exactly.
Tell me about him.
Well, I have to come back to the hour where we lived.
You know, he kind of got a little prank.
And what he thought was funny, wasn't funny all the time.
We go to visit him at the Moussicago, 64, and say, well, us.
So we walk on the street.
My cousin's son, he got a cousin, but we're a special interview to him too.
But anyway, we walk on the street.
All of a sudden, Emmett says in his studded bag, he said,
I got my two big cousins here from Argo, Illinois, and came to the nobody beat him up.
And we looked at him, have you lost your man?
We grabbed him up real quick.
Because the gangs were bad in Chicago, and in the server, you know, gang orientated.
Those kind of things he would do.
And it was funny to him.
It wasn't funny to us, and I don't know how far we're concerned because I was killed.
So I knew how he was.
I knew the things he'd done, you know, as we grew up, you know,
just off color types, you know.
And I just knew when he came in, something could happen.
I didn't think anything would gonna happen, but I knew something could happen.
And just to say, it doesn't sound as if you're saying that these were in any way
hard-edged and beat-spirited things.
He was just playful and provoked the attention of his friends in a playful way.
I never saw him angry, a bit or anybody.
Never.
I didn't even have to do it to him.
He was always doing something though, because he was a center...
If he was there, he was a center of attraction.
And it wasn't planned.
It's just natural.
I told him he's Leo the lion.
He's just a natural leader.
Just needed some directions of time.
But he's gonna do something to get the attention.
When you were 16 and you were saying, read with that name.
And I know you were both down in Chicago and you guys knew each other well and all that.
Was there any part of you being 16 when he was 14?
Did you feel like, oh, I'm a little bigger and older.
I wish I could kind of leave the younger guys behind and go do my thing or was...
Well, Emmett didn't...
He wasn't really...
You're right.
When you're early on age, you most stay within your age.
It's not like now it could span from 70 to 80.
But when you're 16 and 14, you're 16.
Hey, you're 14, you know.
And Samuel was toilet.
He was...
Just set that back up, please.
Samuel was like, the encounter.
You know, back then he just encountered because he was not a...
He was not...
He wouldn't be a player with us.
Let's get the follows and all.
Okay.
Let me have you go back and tell him just that he's different.
Yeah, they age different thing.
And it was kind of like when you go into school.
If you were a man, you're not going to have a girlfriend and settle.
she got to be a senior too.
You know, she got to be in your class.
So there was an age distinction.
And Emmett, he wanted to...
When his mother was taking places, she would take me too, you know.
So he kind of looked up to me, you know.
And I'm not interested in being his leader, but you know, he gets kind of...
I'm the upperclassman, I'm the older person.
So I knew what the deal was, you know.
But he wasn't listening to me and anything.
He looked up to me.
And I thought that age distinction definitely was there.
And you knew it.
Let me have you...
Thank you for that.
Let me have you turn again to Saturday.
27th of August, 25th of August.
Yeah, Saturday, we got home, I think about 12 o'clock, it was dark.
And it's so dark down there.
I mean, if the moon in the night shan, you just cannot see your hand.
You worry for it.
Just dark.
And so we got in with the bed.
And like I said, my race got in bed with my race.
And Simeon Wright, Maurice Wright and Matilda got in bed with Simeon Wright.
It was a big house.
Everybody painted there as a shack.
They insist on calling it a shack.
It was a former landlord, I'm not there to mean anything.
If you look at the house, that's a screen in portrait, Rosalph.
That's money.
And as full screen in portrait, all across the front of the house.
Then you got four big rooms.
You got a little space in between, the kitchen is off to the back.
So it was a very large house.
And I guess about two going forward.
I guess about two, two-thirty and more in my grandfather's house, it was.
I hear these guys talking.
See you wake up.
I woke up.
And man, I became alarmed.
Because they're talking about what happened at the store.
And my man is just racing.
He said, we're looking for a fat boy from Chicago.
I said, man, I'm getting rid of you.
Dad, these people are killers.
Because I heard, all, Simeon Wright and my uncles lived that they had a different take on the South than I did.
I heard all these stories and I took everything literally.
That was one of my problems in life, whatever you said.
Like my mother told me one day, she said, I'm going to kill you (corn stalk whipping) when I get hold of you.
So I, hey, you're going to kill me?
I took off.
I took off running.
You know, she had my uncle with catch me.
I got a whip in the coin because she'd be even with the coin stocks.
So when they said, we're looking for a fat boy from Chicago.
And I heard what they had done to people, kill people and through people in the river and all that.
I said, man, we're getting rid of you.
We're getting rid of you.
Dad, this house.
So the first thing I come back to me is my religious upbringing.
I start praying.
I literally start praying.
You know, just say, God, if you just let me get out of this, I'm going to do it.
It's something about when you think you're getting rid of your dad.
All the wrong things you're done, you know, I could come to you, man.
I was watching World War II film of the day.
And this man's ship had broke up and he was out in this ocean.
And he said, a shark was coming straight for him.
He said, God, if you let me live, I'm going to treat my little brother right.
He said, my Mary or young girl, and I'm going to treat her right.
Your mind changed when death, you feel death and imminent.
You thought a shark went that way and he saw his friends lay who opened the air.
But what I'm trying to say is something about when you think you're closer to death.
You don't have to be the person you think you are.
Your whole demeanor and attitude and value of life just changed.
Nothing else was important to me at that time, but trying to survive.
And the 16th, I was not ready to die.
The quarter of time, I religious up train, I'm bringing in, and I wouldn't fit to die.
So I prayed, you know, I could hear him coming.
And they come in toward my room, on the first room, on the right face in the front of the house, on the first room on the right.
My grandfather was the first room on the left.
So while the time he said we were looking for a fat boy from Chicago, my grandfather had no idea where he was.
So he started, he just started it around.
You remember when I went to my porch?
When I went to my porch.
They came into my room and I could remember.
I'm stretching my eyes, I'm shaking like a leaf on the tree.
And I just didn't want this guy with the gun and one.
And I was always afraid of guns.
I was always afraid of guns.
And we were really afraid of guns because there was a gun left in the house once and he got it.
He could have killed us.
You know, we playing with the gun in the house.
You know, we had those little shifters.
I was afraid of guns.
So they came in and this guy had his pistol and one hand and a flashlight.
It was pure terror.
It's just like if you could just disappear and just go away.
It's like a nightmare.
And things are not ending fast enough.
You know, when I'm waiting, I'm going to be shot.
And I come in and close my eyes.
And they walk past me.
They didn't say anything and they didn't do anything.
It's still scared.
They went to the next room.
Courages are there.
He's there now.
Curtis didn't wake up.
Passed by my Maurice Wright.
He didn't wake up.
They went into the third room where I'll go send me in.
And so I could hear him talking and he aroused him out of the bed.
He had no idea what was going on.
It was like I said, even send me in those guys.
They didn't feel about it like I felt about it.
Simmy didn't know what was going on.
And I could hear him talking.
Not a lot audible or clear stuff, but they were mad at him.
He wanted to put his socks on, shoes, you know.
He'd think he had home, you know.
He don't know who he's dealing with.
And he's saying, yeah, no, he's not saying the right words.
And they were fierce.
I think these guys, in hindsight, I think they had been drinking.
I mean, you have to almost get drunk to do something like what they did.
I feel, I have this real human, had to have some kind of assistance
to do what they did to their kid.
So they found the left and it was dark.
You're going to ask your grandmother tried to intercede
and persuade these men not to take them away.
Was that just part of the general conversation you heard in the other room?
Did you make that clear?
No, they didn't come clear to me.
I was told what she was doing later.
It just conversation going on.
And I knew they were mad.
They were angry.
And I didn't hear anything in it, really, say, but they were angry.
And they left.
And when they left, my grandmother left.
And my grandfather left.
I'm 16, you know, 16.
They didn't have a different 16 now.
I mean, this is the protection.
The protection is gone.
And in my man, they're coming back.
I don't know why.
But in my man, so I'm suffering from pure terror, you know, just, just hail on earth.
So I say, my grandmother would not see.
And she, hey, my grandfather, take her to her brother's house,
she crawls me, thinks up in something.
So I got up.
I said, man, I'll sit there coming back.
I'm putting my shoes on.
I didn't like being bare in the bare feet that much.
So when they come back, when they pull on the yard, I'm here,
it's because the woods are like a some hidden for the woods.
And the strangest thing my uncle and the bear, with me, never woke up.
Maurice never woke up.
Curried as never woke up?
Maurice Wright never woke up.
They woke semi up and told him to go back to sleep.
So it's, you know what you say, but you mean the two men?
Meyland and Bryant.
Yeah.
The, the, the, the Irrigan one, the rig, they didn't just say wake up,
semi up, the Irrigan one, you know, the conversation's over,
he was waking by that.
And, I'm waiting for the, it's in like, they like will never come,
never, never come.
It just so long's.
Nobody talked to anybody.
I didn't wake my uncle up.
I didn't go to the next room.
I just stayed right there.
So when they, my plans, if they come in the yard,
in the yard. I'm here without the back. So the daylight finally came.
Was your brother home? Are you back for home?
No. Well, he came, I don't know exactly what time he got back, but he didn't, he never really bought us together to talk to us.
And we just know that they had, I knew they had taken him. And there was calls being made. Curtis was very courageous.
He went to the land on his house and he called. He was that kind of kid. If Curtis had woke up, it probably, a lot of us probably got killed because he was going to try to do something or say something.
That's kind of personally was. And in metaphor, he became a policeman and he was a bodyguard from the Washington before he did that.
So Curtis did call them. Then his mother called him. It tells my mother. My mother got involved and my daddy had a brother live there.
And he came over and again, he come with a spills. So he is more terrible, you know, so man, it's this real serious.
So he's going to take me from money in the city of the Duck Hill. And somebody in the crowd, I was always a very serious man and a kid.
Somebody in the crowd said, look, we're going to send him up there to get you. Just like that. They did not believe that image is going to be killed.
They still are kind of joking about it. Because the man told me they're going to take him and you know, punishment and bring him back.
So we're going to send him up there to get you. I didn't sleep or wink. From the time 230, for over 24 hours I did not sleep because I looked at my uncle's house and every time my car would go by, I'm looking for him.
You know, I'm looking. And eventually my uncle, he took me to the train station a couple of times to get on.
A couple of time in the reservations and eventually a car to train.
Early that month, I think about five, it was dark, a car to train. Got the Memphis on the way to Chicago.
And I'm going to a washroom and everybody said, you can't go inside. You can't go in there. I'm scared all over again.
I'm thinking, it's so big in the train station, you don't think I'm in Chicago. I'm in Memphis. They got the (washroom) signs, called it.
And it seemed like I was never going to get where I could just relax. So that's where they went that they took him from the house.
I'm going to show you what's the parts of this one.
Maybe you could just say, yeah, we're all in.
So probably you just family away through all that incredibly difficult circumstance back in Chicago.
And therefore you are here at the time of the funeral. And I won't ask about that, but I want to ask about what you would call for that.
There's a few days when we were on our fact that Chicago and Mrs. Till, we sent a family, your parents, just what you think we'll call about those hours of those days.
I arrived at the train station. I can't even remember who picked me up, but I know that they risked me off to Mamie Till-Mobley's house.
We were on 64th and St. Lawrence. And when I got upstairs, everybody was sitting around, saw them, because they don't know what happened to him.
They had not found his body. And they were looking at me and Ms. Till told me to go hold my mother and I did that.
It wasn't too much said, because people just in a grieving state.
And by now they think that something has happened. And I understand they have been searching around bridges and normal places that people have found.
So I got back to Argo and to me it was like a nightmare. In my life kind of resumed as it was. People have asked me about it.
And one day I was in town, I saw a guy, he was named JP, he had a jewelry store. And I saw him and he looked just like him [one of the jurors.
And my heart was just buzzing like a stop beat. And he's here because I didn't put it past and pursuing to do what they wanted to do something to me.
I got pissed up because I realized later that it was the jurors. And I knew him, but he looked so much like him.
It changed my whole life really. It changed. I mean, I could never forget it. And it's like since 1955, it's a constant thing.
I just learned how to handle about my religious upbringing. Talked me how to deal with negative situation. You got the exhale, you got to let it go.
And you have to tell people you full of trouble is how you handle the trouble.
One thing that always bothered me and I don't know if it bothered me, but I can't understand, can't explain is that I went to the funeral.
I said, this is not in me. I said, it's like it never happened. And I say, maybe I'll say say some people ask me, maybe you can stay the shot.
I said, I'm going to see him again. I'm going to show no remorse, no sadness whatsoever. And that's where I live doing those times.
And now I go and talk about it. I see the video and then I'm crying. I got to always be crying now. But doing that time, there was not in it.
I think I knew. That was a monster in there. I always hated him here. I'm going to see him again. That's what I said.
And we believe in here after so we believe you can be again. So I guess that's what I was trying to say. I don't know.
But it changed my whole life. I could never, I could never be the same again. Because it always came to my mind, the promise that you made.
And that was always brought to my attention.
A lot of people just conglomeration of people, you know, the solemn atmosphere there, you know, it's just unbelievable.
I guess you could say just the air was filled with just, I guess, unbelief and how could it happen to a kid?
And just people just felt helpless because the South is even now. If you go on South, around four to five, the highway is going to be packed all the way down.
Because people love to go South. It's like going to Mecca, you know. And this happened. This happened.
So that atmosphere was just a lot of sadness and a lot of unbelief. Because you didn't have history of too many kids being suffering.
But there was one. I don't know if you've seen a book without sanctuary. The photos and as it worked 15 year old kid was hung with his mother.
We're for the most part children were kind of exempt.
Did you see, do you then spend much time with how frequent visits were?
After this, after no, we did because 16 then there were not many automobiles like the South.
Our transportation was by bus. And when I did go over there, we wrote the bus to see him. So and it changed her life too.
Her lifestyle changed. And not only was she working, she went back to college. And she got a college degree. So she's going on with her life.
She's got marriage. And there's a lot of things happening. So we didn't have a whole lot of interaction with her. Just kind of close.
My father had six kids so couldn't afford it. We didn't have a car so we just didn't see that much.
We did see her. I mean, there was times we did see her. Not that much.
Did you find that the whole episode was on your mind frequently as you looked down the food finishing high school and gone on from there? Did you?
Is it something that took a conscious active place in your mind? Very often?
Yes, for sure. Very often. And because of the promise that I made the night to God, I soon forgot about it.
You know, trouble pass. All things right. God has forgotten and the soul just slighted. They're all saying, you know. But every now and then we've reminded of that promise that I made.
So it was always there until I got it right. So these 22, those 16, so six years it took me that long to keep my promise.
Yes, it definitely. I started feeling that if you didn't do it in the Bible, it tells the best not to make a promise and to make it and break it.
So I said that I got to get this right. So when they ask God to help me and I just change and very few people in any church and any denomination in their 20s, you're not going to find it.
Go we trying to get some gusto. We trying to have what we call fun. But after I change, I said, this is the best life. I got I'm peaceful. This is looking for over here. So I got peace and I got happiness.
So I changed and I had no I had no regrets. And this is my 50 year change and I have still have no regrets. It was a hard sale to the young hard sale.
I'm going to want to say that there's a helicopter. Okay, we're all in together.
From what would you say, what would be the easiest say you're in your 20s? Did you travel to Mississippi then?
It was 10 years, well, I was like, I'm 10 years. So I was about 26 when I went back. Then I was conscientious where I went and where I stopped.
Where did you go? I planted uncles like uncle. The one they took me to his house. Just that about two years ago, he's 105. His wife, girlfriend was 69.
He got divorced at the 50 being married 50 years. Never been on any medicine. Worked two miles every day, driving a car.
I mean, I loved to go sit and his daddy was a slave. So I heard those stories. He lived to see his granddaddy. His granddad was a slave. So he was born in 1903, seen him at Fort Motorcoast Star.
And he lived to 1924. So he had a lot of history. So we make sure that we go by and then he had another uncle. He just died at 100 to go by and see him. A lot of relatives.
I just came last week. Still got a lot of relatives. Love to go south.
I'm asking about, um, singing right and his parents. Did you see them much after they came up to Chicago?
Oh, yeah. We lived in the same house.
Oh, excuse me. Of course they did.
Yeah, you know, that extended family. Yeah, my grandfather, my grandmother, they were characters. They were a lot of fun.
How did you, um, miss this question in a careful way? Would you have thought at the time that they're different now because of this?
What's happened or they seem that the personalities were largely intact?
Grandma and Papa after they came here.
To me, it seemed they went on with their life and seemed like the, um, my grandfather had never planned to leave the south. He planned to die in the south.
And, uh, I think he probably had to make an adjustment. He's 60, 70 years old.
But here, even here, he started farming, the farming right over here.
What a teal center is.
And, uh, he started farming and got a job and he traveled.
So I think he made the adjustment. Okay. The kids, Maurice and Simion, Maurice Wright, I think they were glad that he,
and Grandma was here with a family, so she's okay. So they had a good life down there. They had a nice house and they were not sharecroppers.
I think they rented their land.
So they had to make it into them. My grandfather just had had no plans of leaving to move here.
I think Grandma was okay because all of our sisters and brothers were here.
When did the, um, until case come back into your life, say in the form of the journalist or somebody else, a filmmaker, a documentary, and being in touch with you to talk about these things for the first time?
What did that begin to happen, do you remember?
In 1985, Rich Samuels from NBC came out and they did a documentary.
As he met Miss Teal, as a young basketball player, had been killed, Benjamin "Ben" Wilson Jr.
He was a Chicago and she was there for support and he talked with her and as a result, he came and did the story on in material.
Up until that time, to me, it was like, there was no interest in that kind of story. It's like he got what he deserved.
I was in school speaking once and I say, why are we talking about him in tears? He was a man-aged boy that did something that he shouldn't.
I said, well, he didn't deserve the kill and we're here to show you what his sister was like back then.
So that's pretty much the first time Rich Samuels and they did that and then it's like an idea whose time has come.
It's just start happening, you know, others start coming.
And even now, sometimes people don't want to talk about it, you know.
We like to embellish our history and I tell people it's not a nice history is not all good.
In your family, everything's not all good. But you got to tell it like it is, you know.
That's only you can free yourself. That's the one we can deliver yourself is exhale.
Let it go, get it out there and tell it like it is.
So I try to make people comfortable when I tell them about the story.
I'm not here disturbing the earwill animosity but I'm here to just estate the facts.
Don't hate, don't, I tell them don't appreciate or hate the straws of hate.
And I'm not here to bring it up with some of the teachers they don't, I can tell them rather not.
They'd rather for it to go away, you know. But it happened. You got to tell it.
Could you have any special feelings or perspectives on Reverend [Martin Luther] King's visit to Chicago in [19]66?
I just started a business. When La Dosa race was going out, I went into the Army in like '62, got out in '65.
So I just come back to my business and I can remember the hate. I can remember the animosity.
And they were saying that he needed to go back south and I can remember those times, you know.
The way things were there. And you wonder if things would ever change.
The law make you behave with the law can't legislate the heart.
And that's what I was always conscientious of. You know, law can make you treat people a certain way within a certain realm.
But what's in your heart is deep in there. You can't legislate that.
So I definitely remember the King era.
You worked with Keith Beauchamp, when he made the film.
And as momentum grew out of that effort and the federal, the (US) Justice Department and the Mississippi authorities joined me reopen the case.
What were your thoughts and feelings? Did you, how do you evaluate the prospects for this new examination all these years later?
Well, I've often thought of you, who you're talking about is the all of a sudden there's interest, all of a sudden there's momentum trying to do some things.
And you're going to investigate. Yeah, and then players are coming on board. You know, it's just like everything is falling and I don't know one person.
There's a whole lot of conglomeration of things coming together. You got players, you got, which is not mentioned much, Alvin Sykes.
You don't hear much about Alvin. Alvin played a pivotal role. And sometimes what I saw I didn't like because some people act like they own a story.
I say stupid, stupidity. I mean, it's a story that's out there, you know.
And Alvin Sykes was a one that really, (Alvin Sykes) came here with specific one reason to get it open because he had done a case out there in Kansas.
And so he pursued and I went with Alvin and we met with Eric Holder. And Eric Holder felt it referred to him as a legend in his own time.
He pursued, he was a kid, I don't think he had a high school education, but he's well-trenched in the language.
And I guess he studied it over and over and he pursued these sentences about the Till Bill. And then they got (George W.) (George W.) Bush signed a TL bill that allowed $11 million a year for 10 years to be put toward pursuing cases dating back from 1970.
Then he pursued the appropriations [for the Till Bill]. I thought once the bill was passed, the money's automatic. I didn't know you got anything. So he pursued that.
I have a lot of respect for Alvin, a lot of respect for him. And he's so unpretentious. That's what I like about. You're not eagle just.
And you know, it's not, whoever gets the credit, you know, he don't worry about this. So I've been on a million times to support him. So that's what it was like.
Let's get talking a little more about what you, your thoughts on your perspective as the case was reopened by Justice Department and officials in Mississippi and how you looked at that process, what range of motions and feelings that provoked in your sense of how that was handled.
The case was reopened to 2005. I'm interested in your range of thoughts about that as you watched the things that did happen in that process, including the explanation of the body.
Ultimately decision down by Mississippi officials and others not to move forward with any new indictment.
The range of emotion you felt, the range of opinion you had about how all that was handled.
When the first term of that was going to be open, I had a pessimistic view or a negative view. I say, no, we anywhere, all the white men in Mississippi, I open this case, you know what I mean? That's my first thought.
Then it's a well as a woman. I said, maybe you wait a moment. Then it says a black woman, I'll leave you with this child. I said, well, maybe you know, it'll be open.
I was concerned about her, knowing Mississippi, knowing people that you can't legislate the heart, I was concerned about that with one of my concerns.
And how else did I feel? So they gave her the FBI did something that they wouldn't do about 50 years ago. They did the investigation.
I never expected a whole lot because I know that attitude, atmosphere of the country. I know where I'm at. I'm a realist.
I never expected a whole awful lot happening quick, but you know, I know that animosity is going to be still here.
I don't expect no jumping in the bed type thing to happen. Okay. So they gave her an information. I made with the FBI. We did all this stuff.
This is more progress than we ever made. So you appreciate that. We respect that. Now we got the FBI literally and they asked in court and seemed like they maybe kind of serious about getting to the bottom of us.
So she gave it to the grand jury. She grand jury came back to say, FBI thought they had enough information to indict someone.
I'm not interested in anyone getting the data. I'm not interested in anyone going to jail. I'm interested in knowing the facts what happened. I still want to know what happened.
I want to bring some closure to this. Carolyn Bryant Donham, I understand she wanted some one of them to give her immunity. FBI said we can't give you. We're not prosecuting. We just investigate.
Mr. the man that was on the truck with him out of Ohio trying to think of his name. His son out of New York, the end of the door.
He understand that he wanted immunity. He said he didn't know anything about it. He wasn't there. And I can't think of his name. But anyway.
So all of these things are happening. And I'm just kind of going with the flow. And she said they cannot find enough information to indict Carolyn Bryant Donham.
Then Alvin comes with the Till Bill. That helps pursue other cases that has this place. Still not bringing the closure that I want. I want to know what happened. Carolyn Bryant Donham knows what happened.
That's what I would love. That would do me a whole lot of good. I'm not going to bring him back. But I don't know if you understand what I'm saying. Bring closure to know is to have closure.
And you can appreciate that. I don't want to think that happened to her. I leave the woman alone. And I doubted even if they gave him immunity, which you tell truth like it really happened to be very difficult.
A role by our house with the Mississippi. Inversal Mississippi. Literally a retool.
Harding carders. I was a huge from there. We fought. We did the whole. I was with a group of people I had in the business with. But I was there because of the material. I'm not a literary person.
And don't claim that we don't try. I tried. I am who I am. But anyway, it was a very interesting and form and enlightening thing to me.
So those are some of the feelings that I had and to meet with Eric Holden going to the (US) Justice Department. Those are great experiences, talk with the great minds.
But you deal with human beings. And I know I'm dealing with human beings. I know they can only go so far and only do so much.
Did you ever meet Joyce?
No, I don't think so. I don't think I met Joyce. Maybe she did come to Chicago with the FBI. I can't remember. I wouldn't say for sure. I never met her down there.
But she was courageous to do what she did. Her and her is right living in the same town. So that was quite a... I hate some questions about that.
Because you're human. You're dealing with human beings. You're doing this and what's going to happen. People are crazy. Some people may not wrap tight.
So I had some concerns about her. But anyway, she did a great job. I think she did.
Did you have a...
You got a Mississippi recently as we started our conversation. But while back at the premium trail, the inaugural Mississippi Freedom Trail marker ceremony.
Were you able to find any sense of...
What meaning do you find in all of this all these years later?
I probably found more meaning in terms of history. Telling history. And I was always like a little history buff.
And this... It means more to me to see the children benefit from the history part of it than for me personally.
I do it because I went... They let me know they didn't have enough money. And that's how I could pay my own way. Because I want the history to get out there.
So I'm doing it from that perspective. I met down. There was some kids from Dominican High School. Good friend of mine, Mike Smolow. They used a par bearer at Miss Teel's Film. He was on the white par bear.
They were there. So I feel good that I'm able to contribute.
I don't let nobody try to make me a hero or something great because all I did was survive. Scared as I could be. No hero. I'm just survived to tell the story.
So that's my take on it. I don't try to get any miles out of it for myself.
I didn't do nothing. If I could have disappeared, I would have been there.
And it means a lot. People are very appreciative when I come and talk. Being eyewitness, I guess I'm just learning how much it means to them.
Because you tell it over and over and you survived it. It's something that happened that you wish had happened and it was a tragic event.
When people want to hear the story and they want to hear the truth. Especially children. Most of them adults. They have to. They said in their ways and they have their own ideas about things. So that means a lot to me.
John, let's pause for just a second.
Let me ask. Let me ask you about the.
Some of these in Mississippi here in more recent years to memorialize.
They also designated a stretch of highway.
I don't know if you know the story on that coming to pass and your perspective on that.
I think Senator Jordan had something to do with presenting that to the body.
I was there with this ceremony just past a few days ago. I said, that's saying used to be. I thought the same was tall. It says it's been torn down a lot of times.
Not surprised. Like I say, can't legislate the heart. Some people die heart. They're die hearts.
This is a stretch of highway and it's good for history. Not only there, they have a marker. This is going away from the highway.
The Tallahatchie County. I don't know you know about them. They are very much interested in the immatil story. A lot of things happen there.
They have a marker at the spot at the riverways. The bodies will go out. They have a marker by the funeral home that had its body.
They have a marker at the courthouse in Sumner, Mississippi and they're trying to restore that to its original order.
They have a marker by the barn. It's a place where they actually tore it in it. These are things that are good for history and be able to go by and identify with it.
It means a lot to especially history concerning people. The highway and all those things have this place and some people use it and take advantage of something.
They just really don't like it.
So, those efforts in so far as they happen in the cases we've just described, those efforts seem to you well meaning and sincere or are the motives more complicated than them.
I think the people who live there have a lot of, I think, fire trying to write wrongs. But you can only go so far and I appreciate what they're doing.
I think sometimes they become frustrated because again they want to change people's heart. Those kind of things don't change hearts. Believe me they do not and they never will.
But it's good for history. Let it do what it's supposed to do. And I hope they don't get just discouraged because they do all of this and this is the 2000 level.
So this day and time, yeah, this day and time. And The Bible says evil men and seducers will wax worse and worse. That's revival in this country on racism.
I mean we regress and fast, you know, but it was there all the time. It was there all the time. So I just hope they don't get too, become too wrapped up in it in the sense that they expect more than what they're going to get.
Know where you're at. Know what you're doing. Keep doing it. Keep changing. Change is ever made and change is going to be made. It's going to go slow and just hope the God he touched people's heart.
Well, last question. At times you speak to children school children, younger people about all of this history. Do you find that you can communicate successfully to them?
The true nature of all of what that history was back then and nature in Mississippi society then. Are they able to get a hold of all of them?
They're much more receptive to it than the older. The older you get the less receptive you are to it from my experience of talking to people.
I was just at the University of Missouri in Columbia, Missouri, about three weeks ago. And in the college level, you found less receptiveness than you were at eighth grade and you know, the eighth grade level.
And one thing I point out to both of them and blacks. I say the progress and the success that black people made. There was always somebody right there to fight, start to cause.
Otherwise, we would not be here. I say, Abraham Lincoln got a lot of criticism when he tried to handle the rest of the situation. Once he sent 500 African Americans to Haiti, he needed to go get him brother of starving.
So what he did for the time was very noble and courageous. President Kennedy, President Johnson, signed the Civil Rights Bill.
Then I saw them thinking the progress that we meet in all areas. The fire was in some white person's belly to stand up. Civil Rights, the freedom writers, what made it really successful is when the whites came down and joined in.
And the white guy said, I knew I was going to be more targeted than the blacks because they're going to hate me for coming in with them.
So I tell them, I said, look, you guys are going to be sentences or whatever you are. I said, you can make the difference. Do what's right. When white kid told him what I said, well, he said, I'm going to do what's right. I'm going to stand up. I said, you're not going to be liked.
You're just staying too strong and you're not going to be liked. And then I want the blacks to appreciate how God touched hearts and how a lot of this came about.
You didn't fight you way to this. That's why King was so bitter against violence because you're going to be slaughtered. So you have to realize that you got to work together.
We stand and divided. We fall. It all seems still very much very much with us in a very present sense. And it tills case it doesn't seem it's a hard imagine even somehow that it's 56 years ago.
Because there's so much revival. There's so much just being done. He got killed 57 years ago. But all these changes are just coming about.
And he's still in the making. He's still here speaking for so many years. He just laid dormant. There was nothing. You hear about it here and there.
I tell people to me it's like the sathans say, you got what he deserved. And all of a sudden all these changes come by. I mean people were interested.
So it's so much being done. And especially when the young people are the young people are going to have to make the changes.
They're the old people they ain't trying to change. They ain't trying to change. For the most part.
It's been a real honor and pleasure to be with you.
Pleasure to see you.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.